hey guys I'm Billy Eichner and I'm going
undercover on the Internet
this is actually me seriously it's
actually me first up Quorra is Billy
Eichner funny I think he has his days
you know I think I can be funny next
what is Billy Eichner like in person I
get his hysterical on-screen persona and
I find him very funny but would he tell
me to back off if I approached him on
the street I always say I would never
talk to Billy on the street I would
never talk to myself and I'll let you
unpack the psychology around that submit
how did Billy Eichner get his start well
I went to Northwestern I was an acting
major and I thought I was gonna do a lot
of theater and Broadway and things like
that but then I started studying improv
and doing stand-up in New York many
years ago and doing my own live show and
I started doing videos for that show
including on the street videos which
became Billy on the street videos which
went viral and that kind of what
happened Twitter okay but when are Billy
Eichner and Donald Glover going to star
in the producers together maybe Seth
Rogen and I that feels like more of a
producers type of thing what would
Donald Glover and I do a Lethal Weapon
reboot that would be good right I think
I'm the next Mel Gibson and Mel Gibson
would be thrilled about that he loves
gauges Malory naana maker on Twitter
writes when Billy Eichner wins an Oscar
Tony Emmy and Grammy for his work is two
months and the only person who is going
to be more unbearable and that genuinely
made me laugh that's very funny
I know you're not I'm gonna be the most
unbearable already am well thank you
Mary oh this is a response to my own
tweet I wrote I'm a Happy Meal toy and
an emoji and there's nothing you can do
about it hashtag Timon and then
in buyers Road can we get to Mon on the
Savannah where he interviews other
animals a lot Billy on the street no no
we can't tell William's rights if you're
Billy on the street what are you in the
sheets lazy replied
Gina rights how does Billy Eichner not
lose his voice every two minutes because
I'm a [ __ ] pro Gina okay how do
people on Billy on the street not drop
dead Emma Stone and Billy Eichmann were
running towards me and yelling I thinked
well sometimes people do get very
surprised and very scared I'm glad no
one has dropped dead on the show I don't
think you'd actually drop dead I think
you would persevere I find the casting
of Billy Eichner Timon kind of
personally rewarding oh that's nice I
was 15 when the original came out and I
remember conversations about who Nathan
Lane was and how he plays Timon and is
this a gay character as Disney implying
that Timon is gay and does that matter
that's all in quotes well I'm gay Nathan
Lane was gay but you know people keep
asking me if Timon is gay I did a whole
press junket with Seth Rogen no one ever
once asked him if Pumbaa was straight
chew on that Internet I don't know if
Tim owns gay that's fine by me I just
don't know if he is I think we need
openly gay LGBT characters and in family
entertainment so that we don't have to
have annoying decades-long conversations
about whether characters we don't know
are gay or gay just put gay characters
in the thing and it's 2019 and then we
can move on from irritating
conversations and pieces but thank you
someone really Billy on the street has
writers well yeah I mean you know how I
asked like a million questions and how
we build obstacle courses that clearly
had to be built in advance and things
like that yes there are writers who help
me come up with those bits and things
that we do I do think of a fair amount
of it but
you've had very very very hilarious
writers help me think of things you know
the way our TV show works someone
tweeted to Andy Cohen what is Billy
Eichner favorite Billy on the street
moment hashtag watch what happens live
that's hard there have been so many I
loved working with Michelle Obama on a
segment obviously I loved Christmas
caroling with Amy Poehler and I loved
do gay people care about John Oliver
where I took John Oliver out and asked
gay people if they cared about him and
they don't and that I liked did you know
that Billy Eichner who plays Timon and
the Lion King was once a bartender at
the Lion King on Broadway it's the
circle of life yes that is true I was a
bartender at the Lion King on Broadway I
studied to be a bartender but I couldn't
get a real bartending job so I started
bartending at the Lion King actually at
Broadway shows and they moved me to the
Lion King which is not a sign that
you're a great bartender being moved to
the lighting because no one's drinking
martinis at the Lion King because it's
all parents and their kids and so all
you end up doing is pouring sodas and
selling candy and I in a foreshadowing
of my later career as someone who shouts
a lot had to shout over the audience
every intermission that they can bring
the soda into the theatre for act 2 and
I had to yell out all food water and
soda can be brought into the theater
just like that those words are burnt
into my memory and now I have a billion
dollars so much Twitter
I am DB my own personal quote I once
said about Billy on the street nine
times out of ten people are game you
know part of the pun but they are they
might not want to participate they might
just walk by me but they're not angry
once in a while I've had a handful of
occurrences where they are an old lady
slap me across the face really hard
that's true 99% of New Yorkers are like
totally have a sense of humor about it I
mean they might not want to talk to me
but they won't get angry except one
older lady many years ago slapped me
across the
face after I asked her a vaguely sexual
question I thought she had every right
to do that and you know frankly I loved
it
I wish more people would slap me across
the face because that's when you get
those YouTube hits reddit Billy Eichner
has cried after hearing Beyonce singing
The Lion King remake I did Jon Favreau
played me a very early cut of job
Beyonce singing can you feel the love
tonight and I thought it was very
beautiful up next YouTube oh this is for
a Taylor Swift spoof video I did years
ago called glitter and ribs
we've been someone wrote how do you know
he got the mannerisms right vaguely I
was giving you the essence of Taylor
Swift not specifics I mean I'm not going
all Meryl Streep for a Funny or Die
video you know whatever Instagram for a
dollar would you lick Seth Rogen's beard
I I can and I will probably get high off
of it so watching this episode on
YouTube right now instant fan what's
your name on growler kidding ish is
growling I'm still around
sorry growler if you're still around I
keep it classy on Grindr thank you very
much posted someone wrote oh there's a
picture of me on Instagram standing next
to Conan O'Brien and someone wrote but
damn how tall are you then I'm 6 foot 3
Jordan Beckman thank you for the
question you know you can google these
things are you on your way up or on your
way down I'm gonna be optimistic and say
on my way up
but you always could be on your way down
in this wonderful business I'm holding
on to a ladder in this photo and I think
that's what that was a reference to but
I took it to a more profound place as
one should do on actually me boom
alright guys that's it for me thank you
for watching I'm Billy Eichner